Aku nak ajar korang pasal bola yang berpusing — tapi benda tu bukan bola dan ia tak berpusing pun — harini dalam Qiskit in the
classroom kita akan bincang sifat Quantum yang dipanggil spin dengan tengok eksperimen yang mula-mula jumpa bukti untuk
sifat tu. Selamat datang ke Qiskit in the classroom. Dalam siri ni kita guna Qiskit untuk terokai konsep-konsep asas yang selalu
dicakup dalam kursus berkaitan Quantum Computing. Setiap video ada modul interaktif
yang dilink dalam deskripsi bawah, so pastikan korang tengok. Harini kita bincang eksperimen Stern-Gerlach 1922.
Ia antara yang paling famous dalam sejarah teori kuantum sebab ia tunjuk dengan jelas macam mana Quantum
spin berfungsi — tapi bukan tu yang Stern atau Gerlach nak tunjukkan. Eksperimen tu direka untuk uji model Quantum baru
tentang atom yang dipanggil model Bohr, dinamakan sempena Niels Bohr yang cadangkan ia pada tahun 1913. Dalam model tu, elektron bergerak keliling
nukleus dalam orbit diskret, dan boleh bertukar antara orbit tu dengan menyerap atau memancarkan
foton. Setiap orbit ada momentum sudut yang terkuantum, iaitu gandaan integer bagi pemalar asas yang kecil
yang dipanggil H. Masa tu dalam tahun 1910-an dan awal 20-an, mekanik kuantum baru je wujud — baru sangat
sampai ia belum dipanggil mekanik kuantum lagi — so tak semua orang yakin dengan model Bohr. Seorang ahli fizik
bernama Otto Stern benci model tu. Dia panggil model tu karut, malah mengancam nak berhenti fizik kalau Bohr terbukti
betul. Stern memang bertekad nak buktikan model tu salah, so dia reka cara genius untuk uji ia dan
ajak Walther Gerlach tolong reka dan jalankan eksperimen tu. Rupanya dia tak berjaya buktikan Bohr salah — dia
malah buktikan diri sendiri yang salah. Eksperimen diorang sangat mudah dan hasilnya sangat jelas sampai ia lebih kurang
selesaikan debat tu: mekanik kuantum berkuasa di skala atom. Diorang tak sedar masa tu
tapi eksperimen Stern dan Gerlach juga jumpa bukti konklusif untuk spin intrinsik elektron, iaitu satu
sifat asas alam semula jadi yang penting untuk terangkan kemagnetan, kekonduksian super, dan banyak aspek
kimia. Harini aku akan bawa korang tengok macam mana eksperimen Stern-Gerlach berfungsi, apa yang kita jangkakan nak nampak secara klasik,
dan apa yang Stern dengan Gerlach jumpa. Lepas tu aku akan tunjuk korang macam mana nak jalankan eksperimen jenis Stern-Gerlach
sendiri guna Qiskit dan komputer kuantum IBM. Idea asas eksperimen Stern-Gerlach
ialah nak cari cara tentukan sama ada momentum sudut elektron dalam atom tu terkuantum macam yang
Bohr ramalkan, atau tidak macam yang Stern jangka. Diorang guna fakta bahawa momentum sudut elektron juga akan wujudkan
medan magnet kecil sekeliling setiap atom. So korang boleh bayangkan atom-atom tu macam magnet bar kecil.
Eksperimen tu nampak macam ni: ada ketuhar penuh atom perak
dan medan magnet dengan kutub Utara dan Selatan
di sini. Medan tu lebih kuat dekat bahagian atas dan lebih lemah dekat bawah, so ia hasilkan kecerunan yang menghala ke atas.
Akhir sekali ada skrin. Dalam eksperimen tu, ketuhar memanaskan atom perak sampai ia tersejat, lepas tu
atom-atom tu terbang keluar dari ketuhar dengan orientasi setiap magnet bar atom tu rawak sepenuhnya. Kemudian atom-atom
tu lalu melalui medan magnet. Atom-atom akan ditolak ke atas atau ke bawah dengan daya yang bergantung pada arah
kutub Utara setiap atom berbanding kecerunan medan tu. Lepas tu atom-atom tu hantam skrin. Stern dan Gerlach boleh tengok
tempat mana atom-atom tu hantam skrin untuk tahu pasal momentum sudut elektron. Stern jangka bahawa atom-atom
dalam eksperimen tu akan berkelakuan macam yang aku dah cerita — seperti magnet bar kecil yang ikut peraturan
fizik klasik. Secara klasik, magnet atom kecil ni boleh diorientasi ke mana-mana arah rawak, so semasa
bergerak melalui medan magnet, ia boleh alami pelbagai daya berbeza yang menolaknya ke atas atau ke bawah bergantung pada orientasi tu. Magnet yang
menghala ke arah yang sama dengan kecerunan akan alami daya besar ke atas, yang ke arah bertentangan pula
alami daya besar ke bawah, dan kalau ia antara kedua-dua tu, dayanya lebih lemah. Kalau atom menghala
berserenjang dengan kecerunan tu, ia tak alami apa-apa daya dan terus lurus je. Sebab ada pelbagai daya
yang mungkin, atom-atom sepatutnya hantam skrin di titik menegak yang berbeza-beza. Corak yang terbentuk
pada skrin akan nampak lebih kurang macam ni. Tapi tu bukan yang Stern dan
Gerlach nampak. Sebaliknya diorang nampak dua gumpalan atom yang berasingan sepenuhnya pada skrin tanpa langsung ada atom di
tengah-tengah. Diorang tak ada teori yang betul masa tu untuk terangkan benda ni, tapi kita sekarang tahu diorang nampak benda tu sebab
setiap elektron ada sejumlah momentum sudut intrinsik dalam bentuk spin, yang hanya boleh ambil salah satu
daripada dua nilai. Dalam gambaran magnet bar kita, ini bermakna ada hanya dua orientasi yang dibenarkan untuk magnet atom. Kita panggil
dua orientasi ni spin up dan spin down. Sebuah qubit dalam komputer kuantum
menyerupai sistem spin jenis ni, dan sesetengah komputer kuantum sebenarnya guna qubit yang dibuat daripada keadaan spin elektron.
So kita boleh jalankan eksperimen Stern-Gerlach sendiri dengan Qiskit dan qubit dalam komputer kuantum IBM. Jom kita
petakan keadaan spin up elektron sebagai keadaan sifar qubit dan keadaan spin down sebagai keadaan satu
pada qubit. Masa zarah perak keluar dari ketuhar, momen magnet diorang diorientasi secara rawak. Kita
boleh model eksperimen Stern-Gerlach dengan buat circuit Quantum ringkas dengan satu qubit bermula dalam keadaan sifar.
So ni dipanggil rajah circuit di mana wayar atas adalah qubit dan operasi yang dikenakan pada qubit
muncul sebagai kotak pada wayar. Kotak RX dan RZ ialah gate Quantum yang
secara berkesan putar orientasi magnet atom. Kita boleh pilih nilai Theta dan F rawak kat sini untuk putar
qubit secara rawak. Ini tirukan ketuhar yang keluarkan atom dengan orientasi spin rawak. Kotak kelabu ialah
ukuran kita. Ia beritahu kita sama ada qubit dalam keadaan sifar atau satu, dan hantar ukuran tu ke bit klasik yang
dilabelkan C dengan garisan berganda. Bahagian ni setara dengan mengukur sama ada atom dalam spin up atau spin down dengan tengok
tempat mana ia hantam skrin. Kita boleh guna Qiskit primitive yang dipanggil sampler untuk jalankan eksperimen banyak kali, setiap kali dengan
nilai rawak berbeza untuk Theta dan f. Selepas 100 sampel, kita dapat histogram ukuran yang nampak macam ni — lebih kurang
50% masa qubit diukur sebagai sifar dan 50% masa ia dalam keadaan 1. Ini adalah hasil yang sama yang Stern
dan Gerlach nampak — ia sentiasa sama ada spin up atau spin down, tapi tak pernah antara kedua-dua. Pada ketika ni korang mungkin fikir,
WEBVTT
"Mestilah kita dapat dua keputusan diskret — kita jalankan eksperimen pada komputer kuantum digital yang hanya pernah pulangkan
sifar atau satu." Dan memang betul. Tapi ingat, sebab sebenar komputer kuantum pulangkan keputusan perduaan — malah
sebab Quantum Computing berfungsi langsung — adalah tepat-tepat sebab kuantisasi spin inilah yang Stern dan Gerlach mula-mula temui.
Qubit dalam komputer kuantum IBM bukan berasaskan spin, tapi banyak komputer kuantum lain memang berasaskan spin, so dengan jalankan eksperimen
Stern-Gerlach pada komputer kuantum, kita sebenarnya boleh jumpa semula kuantisasi spin.
Sejak 1922, banyak sambungan kepada eksperimen Stern-Gerlach asal telah dijalankan. Sambungan-sambungan ni melibatkan
menghantar alur atom yang sama melalui beberapa radas Stern-Gerlach untuk tengok macam mana spin berkelakuan dalam situasi berbeza.
Ni salah satunya: jom hantar atom melalui satu radas untuk pisahkan alur kepada dua, sepadan dengan alur
spin up dan alur spin down, lepas tu hantar setiap alur tu melalui radas berasingan masing-masing.
Dengan Qiskit, circuit Quantum yang sepadan dengan eksperimen ni lebih kurang sama dengan yang tadi tapi dengan dua
ukuran bukannya satu. Di sini kita dah gantikan putaran rawak yang tirukan kesan ketuhar dengan
gate yang dipanggil Hadamard, sebab guna Hadamard akan bagi kita kebarangkalian ukuran yang sama macam ketuhar tadi
tapi lebih mudah guna. So kita ukur sekali, kemudian dua kali, dan
histogram ukuran yang terhasil untuk eksperimen tu nampak macam ni, di mana rentetan bit pada paksi X sepadan dengan
keputusan dua ukuran tu. Kalau qubit diukur sifar dua kali, itu sepadan dengan rentetan bit 0 0. Atau kalau
diukur sifar dulu kemudian satu, itu sepadan dengan satu sifar dan seterusnya. Nampaknya kalau diukur spin up dalam
eksperimen pertama, ia akan spin up dalam eksperimen kedua juga. Sama dengan atom spin down. Maksudnya dalam eksperimen pertama
kita ada kebarangkalian sama untuk ukur ke atas atau ke bawah, tapi menjelang eksperimen kedua, keputusannya dah ditentukan. So
dua skrin di hujung setiap radas Stern-Gerlach kedua masing-masing akan ada hanya satu titik. Satu skrin akan ada
semua atom spin up dan satu lagi semua atom spin down. Untuk eksperimen seterusnya jom
mulakan dengan alur atom spin up tulen. Dengan eksperimen fizik Stern-Gerlach yang sebenar, korang boleh buat ni dengan hantar
diorang melalui radas Stern-Gerlach dan sekat alur yang deflected ke bawah, so semua atom yang deflected ke atas adalah
spin up. Sekarang jom hantar alur ni melalui radas Stern-Gerlach lain, tapi kali ni jom putar magnet 90° so
kecerunan medan akan deflect atom yang bergerak ke arah ini ke kiri atau ke kanan. Adakah kita akan nampak satu titik atau dua atau sesuatu yang
berbeza sepenuhnya? Untuk eksperimen ni
kita akan jalankan circuit berikut dengan Qiskit. Kita mulakan dalam keadaan sifar sebab alur atom dalam eksperimen ni semua
spin up. Kemudian gate Hadamard ni tukar koordinat x dan z so ia berkesan putar
radas Stern-Gerlach tu. Sekarang kita mengukur unjuran spin ke kiri atau ke kanan bukannya ke atas atau ke bawah. Di sini kita dapat
histogram ukuran yang nampak macam ni. So kita nampak bahawa spin sepanjang X juga hanya boleh ambil dua nilai
yang boleh kita panggil spin left dan spin right. So eksperimen ni tunjukkan bahawa kalau korang ukur unjuran X bagi spin
yang sebelumnya diukur spin up sepanjang Z, ia akan jadi spin left atau right dengan kebarangkalian yang sama. Jom kita bandingkan
satu kali lagi dengan jangkaan klasik untuk benar-benar tonjolkan perbezaannya. Secara klasik, ingat aku cakap kalau magnet bar atom kecil tu menghala
berserenjang dengan kecerunan medan magnet radas tu,
daya pada atom tu sepatutnya sifar. Ia tak sepatutnya deflected ke atas atau ke bawah — dalam kes tu kita nampak hanya satu titik di
tengah skrin. Sebaliknya kita nampak dua titik, so separuh atom spin left dan separuh spin right walaupun
sebelum ni diorang diukur ke atas. So dari perspektif mekanik kuantum, walaupun mungkin menggoda nak
samakan spin up dengan vektor yang menghala ke atas dan spin down dengan vektor yang menghala ke bawah, ia tak sesimple tu macam yang kita nampak
dari eksperimen terakhir. Untuk faham betul-betul apa yang berlaku kat sini, kita kena pergi lebih dalam ke topik
superposisi kuantum dan pengukuran, yang akan jadi video untuk hari lain. Sama macam kita masih ada lebih banyak
soalan tentang macam mana mekanik kuantum berfungsi, Stern dan Gerlach pun ada soalan yang sama. Eksperimen diorang tak terangkan
segalanya, tapi ia banyak membantu dalam menegakkan mekanik kuantum sebagai penting untuk faham alam semula jadi.
Ia antara eksperimen asas yang paling penting dalam mekanik kuantum yang terbukti kuantisasi
momentum dan bagi bukti untuk sifat asas alam semula jadi baru yang dipanggil spin. Untuk benar-benar bergumul dan
faham peraturan dunia kuantum, ahli-ahli fizik macam Stern dan Gerlach kena kotor tangan diorang dengan reka
eksperimen, buat ramalan, dan kadang-kadang salah. Memang tak ada pengganti untuk cuba sendiri.
So kalau korang nak cuba jalankan beberapa eksperimen Quantum yang sebenar, pergi ke modul Stern-Gerlach
yang dilink dalam deskripsi. Terima kasih kerana menonton, jumpa korang next time.